- So when I first saw your book,
I had one word, I was like damn!
(audience laughing)
Get it!
Like I can't hang with you anymore!
Come on, like you are so fit.
I'm gonna put this by my treadmill
in hopes that it will motivate me.
- Well, I don't know about that,
you know everybody's got
their own journey for sure.
- Oh my gosh.
- And for me, you know,
the only reason we wrote the book was,
usually you get five or 10 minutes
when you're doing interviews, as you know.
And it's usually about
where you're touring,
when's your tour start,
when's your album coming out,
what's your next single.
- It's not necessarily in depth.
- How are the kids and all that.
Oh,, by the way you got in
shape, how'd you do that?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we got two minutes,
and you never have time to
really say all of what it does.
And it's really, as much physical,
it was mental for me in a lot of ways.
(audience cheering)
- I mean, yeah, that's just a few photos
from the book of life.
- It's painted, it's all photoshopped.
- That ain't painted,
you worked hard for that.
What inspired you to get in shape?
- Well, I had been an
athlete my entire life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I come from a long line of athletes.
My dad was a professional baseball player,
my uncle was a professional
baseball player,
so I have some athletic DNA in me.
And I was an athlete my
whole life growing up
and I kinda let that get away from me.
You know, being on the road
and being part of that lifestyle
and not taking care of yourself.
- And like going from
one place to the next,
it's hard to like eat healthy.
- Yeah, it's hard.
- It's a lot harder.
- It's tougher, but you just have to
dig a little deeper and find it.
But you know I was going
through a tough time in my life,
I lost my dad, who I was
just getting to know.
My dad died at 59 of brain cancer,
and I didn't know him growing up,
so I was just getting to know him.
And then my stepdad passed
away during that time,
and my grandparents, and my coach
who was a real mentor to me.
- That's a lot of loss.
- So it was a lot of loss, but you know,
a lot of times we fall back
and use things as excuses as well too.
And I was going through a
thing with my record label.
So, everything is relative to everybody,
you know, no matter what
station of life you're at,
or how much money you make or don't make
or whatever job you have,
everybody has issues to deal with,
and you gotta find a
way to deal with them.
And I was dealing with them the wrong way.
And my wife told me I needed
to get my stuff together,
- Yeah.
- And then I was at a movie-
- Did she say stuff?
(Audience laugher)
I know she's a Mississippi
girl, she did not say stuff.
- She's a Mississippi girl,
she can be quite colorful
with the English language.
- Yes me too.
- Absolutely, but then we were at a movie.
We took the kids to see
a movie, a holiday movie,
and this was, I guess, 10 or 11 years -
Gracie's 22 now so she must
have been 10 or 11 years old,
so it was a while back.
I had done a movie that I sort of,
wanted to sort of not think about,
and didn't think about
the trailer being on,
and it wasn't that it was a bad
movie or anything like that,
I just didn't like me.
But, sure enough, the first
thing that popped on the screen
was the trailer of the
movie that I was in,
and my face on a hundred-foot screen,
and my daughter Gracie
looks at me and says,
"Jeez dad, you need to do something".
(Audience laughter)
- Dude, I'm telling you kids
are wrong, kids are wrong.
- But to me, it was
funny, and she meant it,
but she meant it in a lot
of different ways I think,
because kids pay more attention
to a lot of things in your life
than what you ever realize
that they pay attention to,
and she meant it in a
lot of different ways.
And it was sort of a clarity call for me.
And it wasn't overnight,
it was a gradual process,
and it was, you know, three
steps forward and two steps back
and it always is and it always will be.
You're never going to arrive at a goal,
you're always working
to get to some place.
But what I've found is, trying to keep up
a consistent physical
practice has helped me
find other disciplines and other things.
And, you know, we think of discipline as
sort of this cage that
your put yourself in
when you decide to apply
discipline to your life.
What I've discovered is discipline really
opens the door to the cage that you're in,
and it allows you to find other
things that you're good at.
- Is this all in the
book? Because I'm like-
- [Tim] Well most of it's in there, yeah.
- I'm just saying, I'm in, this is wow.
- Well it works, you know.
The stronger you build your platform,
the higher you can leap, and
that what I'm trying to do,
and that what I want
everyone to experience,
and hopefully somebody will get -
if one person gets something
out of it then right on.
- I already have, I told
you, right by the treadmill.
It's like, it's amazing.
Okay so, how did you,
I know that you went to the physical part
and it kinda helped you
mentally and emotionally,
but how do you deal with that much loss?
Like to other people,
like because I feel like
we all experience things
to have a testimony
to tell other people,
to get them through it as well.
- Absolutely, for me, you know,
after you sort of realize the loss,
you look at what you have.
- [Kelly] Amen.
- I had a lot of great things in my life.
I mean, I have the best wife that I could
ever imagine myself having.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I got three great daughters.
And I got a great career,
coming from a small town in Louisiana
where I grew up with nothing in my life,
except for the love of a mom.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Without any - and my grandparents.
Without that, I don't
know where I would be.
So to be at that place in my life,
to have all the things I ever possibly
could dream of in my life,
it made me look around and say,
you know, I got a lot
more to be thankful for
than to worry about the cycle of life.
- What a beautiful way
to turn that around.
- Yeah, well, you know,
with a Mississippi boot in your ass too.
(Audience laughter)
- She's like look here sir.
Do you work out with Faith,
does she work out with you?
- She works out yeah, you know-
- [Kelly] Because she
always looks so good!
- She's pretty hot.
- [Kelly] I know!
(Audience laughter)
- She's pretty hot.
- I know.
- As the kids have grown up,
and as the kids have gotten older,
we find that we're getting to spend
a little bit more time
together in the gym downstairs,
so I'm enjoying that for sure.
- [Kelly] That's so cool, all right.
I also was reading your pre-interview
and I didn't know that you love to cook.
- [Tim] I love to cook.
- You and Faith cook, yeah.
- We both cook, Faith's
a fantastic cook, I mean-
- [Kelly] Yeah I bet.
- She can cook anything.
- [Kelly] She does everything great too.
- She does everything.
- She's beautiful.
(Audience laughter)
- I know, she married way below
- Whatever, whatever.
- But yeah, she's a great cook.
I do the staples, I mean
we cook some healthy,
a lot of healthy stuff,
but we cook some stuff that's
not so healthy as well.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I mean chicken and dumplings
is a big go-to at our house.
- Yeah, it's Southern.
- That's sorta how I hooked Faith,
was with chicken and dumplings.
- What do you mean you sorta-
- I took 'em to her house.
We were touring together, I
didn't know her that well,
and she lived right down the road from me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I made some chicken and dumplings,
and I thought, you know, I'll take some
chicken and dumplings and some cornbread
down to Faith Hill and we'll
see how that works out.
- I just wanna, I wanna
be a fly - it worked.
I wanna be a fly on that wall.
- I still cook them every now and then
to see if it still works.
- You're like you still love me right?
(Audience laughter)